gift of a dog from a path for Paws
Rescue here to tell us all the important
things that you should keep in mind
before adopting we have Foster
coordinator Laura Ward and Laura you
brought a friend with you today who is
this yes this is Angel she's an 11 year
old pitbull mix she's looking for her
forever home she is perfect and everyone
just wants to come up and pet her and
she cuddles and she loves on everyone
and she is just too cute thank you for
being here sorry it's hard to get
distracted you know not to get
distracted I get it tell us a little bit
about the organization what you guys do
and you said you yourself have been
fostering for over 20 years that's
amazing we have yes we have so our path
for Paws has been rescuing abandoned and
stray dogs for we've been around for
about five years
so we take in dogs from the shelter that
are on the kill list or owners that can
no longer keep their dogs and we get
them all ready for a new home we get
them spayed and neutered
um shots if they need shot all of their
shots a dental if they need dental and
microchipped and then we find them a
great home well thank you for everything
that you're doing in our community we
need even more of you out there because
there are so many dogs to go around and
the holidays are a popular time to maybe
get a pet for your family Angel is over
she's like I'm ready to find a home I
know she is she's like things do you
have you know to advice to give to
people before they necessarily adopt or
you know just talk with your family what
would you suggest doing
um I may suggest you know look at your
lifestyle
um do you work 10 hours a day are you
active you know do you want a dog that's
going to be active with you hike or run
so you know look at your your lifestyle
and then base the dog on that
um you know on your lifestyle so you
know do you have time for a puppy that
takes house training and you know
socialization or do you need more of a
laid-back Couch Potato that's gonna want
to short walk around the block and then
a nice cozy bed so well it's important
to have those conversations because
sometimes just gifting someone a pay
isn't necessarily the best because you
got to make sure you're prepared and
ready for it so do you just suggest
having those open conversations before
giving a pet as a present absolutely
absolutely and that's one of our
policies at our adoption center that we
want everybody that everybody in the
household present to meet the dog and
just see how everybody likes the dog
because it's a commitment you know it's
a commitment for their lifetime so we've
got to make sure it's a good fit yeah
but the best commitment Angel is
actually up for adoption if people want
to adopt angel or any of the other dogs
that you have where can they go for more
information so they can go to our
website at pathforpaws.org we are also
we have adoption center it's on the 95
in Jones right next to the CAL Ranch
store we're there every Saturday and
Sunday ten to four you don't need an
appointment you can come in Meet the
dogs we do ask if you have another dog
or two in the home to bring the dogs for
a meet and greet and thank you this is
really really special and if you want to
adopt angel or any dogs there's all your
information we'll be